he is the pride of sweden plays
internationally for sweden he's been all
over the world he's played for some of
the greatest soccer clubs Manchester
United he played in Italy and now
playing for our LA Galaxy he is
slots on ibrahimovic and he joins us on
the program
why did salat on decide to come to Los
Angeles
why is Lawton decided to come to Los
Angeles because I wanted to give them
the best gift ever and what do I get
myself to Los Angeles well I'd like to
say thank you on behalf of Los Angeles
and the rest of America for you bringing
your talents over here and just like the
edge you're welcome what what is it
about America that you love I think
America is a good nice country I've been
here a lot of times on vacation and I've
been like New York Miami Los Angeles and
I think Los Angeles is the city that
fits me most and is a city that looks
more like my little Sweden not really
but almost how how popular are you in
Sweden how popular yeah yeah I don't
think you can measure
I am Sweden I am NOT viadon oh so so if
I go to the dictionary and I say that
you know it's Sweden and a picture of
you comes up as the definition of Sweden
yeah yeah yeah sure the name Sweden took
my name so when you navigate in Sweden
you don't you don't read Sweden you're
right but I like it and I believe you I
believe you're telling the truth what's
the fan reaction here in the United
States been so far I have to be honest
it has been super positive everybody is
kind kindly and making me feel welcome
people see me on the streets and they're
like thank you for coming
welcome to LA only positive positive
vibes everywhere
give me the celebrity you want to meet
yeah don't wanna miss nobody they wanna
meet me
I could see you act are you thinking
about doing movies when your soccer
career is done I don't know little bit
curious but I'm not there yet but you
never know you never know yeah because I
could have you as a sidekick to the rock
or some of these other guys you know if
Schwarzenegger starts doing movies again
what do you think or do you want to be
like a leading man leading man something
like Rambo Bourne Identity because I
think I have the skills to do do those
things I like it somebody says the bad
guy in the movie because my English is
like Ivan Drago but he must have better
than that when did you know you were
good at soccer
I mean I think in the beginning I had so
much confidence so whatever I would do I
think I would succeed because in
everything you do whatever it is ports
or something else 50% is in your head
and the rest is trained at that said oh
and all those small details that also
makes the difference so whatever we
choose I would do good so the lucky
thing was that the football house but I
chose football best player you ever
played against best player I have to say
Paolo Maldini so he played in Italy he
played in Italy I was in Intel I was in
IX and he played in Miller and he made
me do more than I needed to do on the
field to do good so he brought he
brought out of me 200% who is the best
player in soccer in the world now I have
to say Messi if I cannot say myself then
let's say mess
what makes Messi better than everybody
else
I think it's just natural he is not
trained is not obviously built in a way
that he has to do things is just natural
is Ronaldo - pretty cool
do Cristiano Ronaldo if he is what -
pretty yeah - pretty sad I don't look at
him like that did you see that statue
they had of him that they just made
recently is there is a lot on statue
somewhere it's coming it's coming to
Sweden that's what I mean you go to
Sweden you say you talk to me in this
radio so yeah you have everything you
need when I get to the airport how long
before I land in Sweden before I am
reminded that you own this country the
first step you put in the country you
will feel just like I did in LA it was
their earthquake when I stepped up that
airplane yeah any chances of you being
in the World Cup let's see I said
yesterday in the Jimmy Kimmel show I'm
going there so I will be there you will
by the way great appearance on Kimmel
show yeah and it's the first time money
I mean in the passenger seat normally I
mean the drivers I'm the first one out
but it was okay for this time I needed
to make him famous also this Jimmy how
nervous were you going out there now
they were like in the beginning like
don't be nervous
be yourself and these things because
other at least at least has been there
and I mean they get close when they go
in to see the audience I just listen
open the door and let me run this show
maybe maybe you could fill in for Kimmel
one night yeah they told me whenever I
want I take over the show already
yesterday I wanted to take over because
I felt the crowd I felt a positive wide
I felt the energy and that is wherever I
go in LA I feel that energy from there
from the people and yesterday I felt the
same thing and I just want to give give
back to them but by being myself
not by acting how many languages do you
speak
hi
four or five English with little alcohol
wait with with alcohol you speak ten
languages ten languages without twice
is there a much trash talking going on
in these matches people will say things
to you yeah what are they saying
nada every dirty things everything
whatever you want to say to get them out
of balance you say it is part of the
game what's your nickname my nickname
which came in Italy when I was playing
theirs because they couldn't say it by
him or which so they went for Ebro cebra
Libre yeah that is what they called me
in the football world
how does the United States get back into
the World Cup I don't know maybe I
should change the first place can can we
acquire you how much you think it would
cost to acquire your talents
what's the transfer fee I have a wife I
did my two kids if I would be single I
would spread some investments here in in
the US and you would have a future
legend in the soccer but sorry I'm I'm
already occupied by my wife and I took
his hey it's a great talk to you thanks
for coming to America and good luck with
the rest of the season with the galaxy
thank you thank you good luck with
everything and take care for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]